I go inside--
What is it?
Oh, can't I get
one fucking day off?
Shit.
Listen to me, you ass.
I just spent
the last 20 days
running around,
saving the world
from apocalypses,
only to keep trying
to save the world.
Now I am stuck
in this pubescent body,
my hormones are raging,
and all I wanna do
is go out and buy
a 1970s Corvette Stingray.
Take it easy on him, Five.
Lila, this is between me
and myself,
so stay out of it.
Then why are you doing this?
Because he is an idiot.
Who the hell are you?
Hi, I'm his loving brother.
Yeah, come on, Five.
We gotta figure this out.
OK. How about
we take a step back?
Look at
the big picture here.
I just spent
the past 20 straight days
saving the world, twice.
Can I get five minutes
to relax
before figuring
all the new kinks out?
Please and thank you.
Oh, well, since you asked
so nicely, sister mine,
our little paradox
brought forth
a freaking Kugelblitz.
I don't trust him.
But he's you.
Exactly.
You think
I wanna shoot a kid?
And go home with that
on my conscience?
Well, I wouldn't worry
about that.
You won't be going home.
What exactly
have we accomplished?
Well, we made some friends
along the way.
Incorrect!
You know what we've done?
Nothing. We made things
worse every single time.
Any closer
and I'll melt your brain.
In the end, I had to project
my consciousness forward
into a suspended quantum
state version of myself
that exists across every
possible instance of time.
That makes no sense.
Well, it would
if you were smarter.
-Hey. Can you go any faster?
-Ask me again
and I'll burn you
with the cigarette lighter.
Wouldn't your son be happier
playing with kids his age?
Assuming it's OK
with your two dads.
I would rather chew off
my own foot.
Do you like jazz, Five?
I'd rather lick
a cheese grater.
I'm the daddy here!
Hey, Chatty Cathys,
quit the chit-chat, alright?
I'm calling
a family meeting here.
Lose the crazy lady
and come with me.
We have important business.
Newsflash, geniuses.
It's not about us.
It was a simple task!
All we had to do
was be here!
Didn't have to fight
a giant sea monster, no.
An army of mutants? Nein!
I can't believe this.
It was handed to us
on a silver platter.
Could you just moan
a little softer?
My head is killing me.
Listen to me,
you useless puke-bag.
We just blew our chance
to save the world!
I'm sorry, OK? I'm sorry.
I just needed somebody
to come with me
for emotional support.
Oh, emotional support?
Like a Schnauzer?
Now you listen here,
young man.
No. You listen
to me, asshole.
I've come a long way
for this,
through some shit
your pea-brain
couldn't even comprehend.
So just give me
the information I need
and I'll be on my merry way.
And if you call me
"young man" one more time,
I'm gonna put your head
through that damn wall.
Oh, dear.
Oh, who's Diego?
Imagine Batman,
then aim lower.
Have a look around.
If you hadn't noticed,
there's no doomsday,
there's no apocalypse.
The sun is shining.
Birds are doing
whatever the hell birds do.
That's all that matters.
We're done messing
with time.
And I'm officially retired.
Yeah, and I knew you
wouldn't come if I told you,
so what was I
supposed to do?
Goddamn right,
I wouldn't, Klaus.
You know why?
Because I…
-am supposed to be retired!
-I know.
This was supposed to be
a carefree road trip.
Well, it still can be, babe.
Ball of Twine? Klaus, turn!
Ball of Twine!
-Turn!
-What? Five!
-Don't!
-It is one of the best ones!
-Come on!
-Five, we're gonna die!
-I don't care!
-Let go!
-Goddammit.
-Shit!
It is a giant
trash compactor
which is winding up
the universe
and consuming it whole,
so tell me
how you stop it!
That's one badass stapler.
The kid wants coffee. Black.
Cute kid.
Then I should probably
get that ink.
Complete the loop.
Are you sure?
Oh, I don't think destiny
cares whether I am or not.
Bitch is cruel, ain't she?
Leave the pot here.
Thank you.
Lippy little shit.